in Brooklyn New York lies the historic
neighborhood of Cobble Hill a hip
thriving area and home to Sal's Pizzeria
run by John Esposito my parents came
here from Italy and they took over this
Pizzeria in 1970 and at the age of 14 I
left High School to help my mom and dad
run the business this has become my life
ever since
hello Sal so can I help you
we ran the place very successfully thank
you by the 90s we were able to purchase
the restaurant next door hello how are
we doing
my mom became sick she got diagnosed
with cancer we thought the right thing
to do was to name the room after my mom
that's why you have Sal's pizza and Mama
Maria's his father passed away his mom
passed away he was the only one in
charge of everything
and as the U.S it started to go down
we don't have that kind of volume of
sales that we once had then I can't
figure out the reason why I dropped off
where's the people I've stayed the same
I haven't changed they weren't a fan of
the Eggman I don't know what they're
doing over there John as the owner is
supposed to be in charge of this whole
place including the kitchen but he's
usually up front making pizzas covered
in in flour
are two different animals that's like
the accountant I thought it'd be cool to
open a wine bottle stop paying attention
over here for a minute get in the
kitchen really look at what's going on
John treats this place like his second
home
he's got four kids that are always here
running around the restaurant okay
it doesn't really look good for the
restaurant
John is an extremely stubborn owner all
right so this is the way we're going to
set up the table Listen Hold the rear
Rose and don't get down here it's my
restaurant in his mind the system has
worked but it really stopped working
like 20 years ago
Cobble Hall used to be a very old school
Italian neighborhood but now we have
much much younger people moving in a lot
of people like to call them hipsters
sorry uh spaghetti doesn't taste quite
right I don't know what to tell you it's
a fresh tomato sauce throw this up am I
going to put on plastic glasses get a
funky haircut put an earring in my ear
just to accommodate the new people name
I'm not gonna do that how are things on
this side not bad horrible really yeah
John is holding on to the past and to
the way things were done when his
parents ran the business we didn't do
anything today we didn't even do a quart
of what we used to do
any businessman would have said enough
is enough pull the plug but how do you
pull the plug on family history pretty
tough
we gotta do something to boost these
checks this place is Mom and Dad losing
one Cycles in a pound again that might
prepare to handle that
[Music]
Mama Maria's what is that that is
ghostly holes everywhere that is not a
good sign
my goodness me
hello how are you kid how are you first
name is Fabia yeah good to see you I'm
the manager here that outside looks like
an eyesore whose idea was that the owner
he actually cut the letters out what I
guess because it was tearing and he just
completed the whole thing
and the owner is John and he is where
next door he's responsible for like the
pizzeria so two restaurants right my
memory is I'm standing in right and then
there's Sal's Pizzeria next door
um right I'm gonna go meet the owner
thank you no problem wow
so Sal's Pizzeria
John who's there how are you very much
how are you good thank you excellent so
are you filling in today someone phoning
sick I pretty much make the pizzas yeah
I always work the front of the counter
so you're buying that constant yeah wow
how long have you making pizzas since
I'm 10 years old that's incredible I got
confused with That Hideous canopy
outside was that you cut holes in the
canopy
uh actually the wind dead the wind did
that yeah
Anyway come around let's have a catch up
okay first of all give me a little
insight the history my mom and dad had a
pizzeria and my father my mother did all
the cooking in the back by the 90s my
mom got sick she came down with cancer
she passed first I'm sorry he's no
longer with it wow so that's why it has
two different Mom and Dad Sal and Maria
right combined restaurants what is the
number one problem here we're not busy
you're not busy uh there's more
competition in the neighborhood than
we're struggling we're struggling to
keep the doors open it's a high pill to
swallow yeah I can see that
um
I'd like to these and find out what's
going on here
it's very uncomfortable for me to sit
here right now and ask for help thank
you I'm not feeling who I am I feel weak
oh hello hello how are you good how are
you and this is Laurie Laurie nice to
see you what would you do I'm a waitress
excellent what's wrong with the
restaurants
um lack of leadership uh John's a little
frantic chaotic um usually very busy in
Pizzeria John has been here forever so
you would think John would know how to
run this place but he doesn't want to
change anything because this is what his
parents knew before they passed away
homemade pastas pasta made daily on the
premises all the pastas made fresh on a
daily basis yep okay
um start off with the tortellini potato
okay I gotta try the speed of Meatballs
Margarita please okay thank you
wow
Mongolia oreganata second course you got
the tortellini patate the food is not
good here but it's not my food I'm
serving it the same way we always serve
it oh boy I think the Chef Ramsay's
gonna have a heart attack when he sees
what goes on around here oh my God
oh hello Hi how are you
so they showcase the desserts
hmm
so this is our desserts everything's
made here fresh on premise right so jeez
what is that it's butter it's oh it's
butter yeah just to display as the ice
cream
and that uh that mold on there you show
that no the Butter's on top so it covers
that
and that bit there yeah and Fabio you're
the general manager right so you've got
no idea this we're presenting those
moldy bits of [__]
and it's stuck with butter on top now
those are just for a display hold on
because they're for display you've got
the right to cake them in mold and serve
customers a display that's full of mold
so we're supposed to like put a fresh
one every day so we can throw it out are
you kidding me
what do you think I think that you know
as long as it's I mean it's fresh it's
good I mean I wouldn't but I wouldn't
are you I mean have you lost the plot
no I haven't
it's changed colors four times and it
absolutely reeks all I'm saying is that
this is for a display we're not serving
it so do the customers deserve a display
that's full of [__] oh my God this is
look at this mess
oh my God that it must be two months old
it's probably a few days old a few days
uh uh we don't serve it it's for
presentation I'm aware you're not
serving thanks [__] gold star
congratulations on that one that's so
that's a big breakthrough with you
that's why you're here excuse me that's
why you're here I'm here to tell you
that that [__] and you should be
presenting it you don't know the
difference between mold and fresh it's
for presentation give me two seconds I
need clean my hands I'm caked in mold
I've got disgusting butter and I've got
[__] hands full of pus oh my god
oh Christ Almighty we got Tylenol
according no
yeah
he's gonna come forward at it I'd rather
him crowded us than we serve it there
thank you
[Music]
I don't know it's bland I mean really
Bland and Visually it looks like
someone's
just eating that whole dessert tray and
it shot out twice as quick as it went in
Laurie it's just Bland I read a black
I'll let them know and this is frozen
because there's a grainy potato flavor
inside that I don't think anything's
Frozen Here Yeah so the totally done
Frozen I'll double check thank you
uh-oh you said it was very very Bland he
asked if the um the tortellini were
frozen I wasn't sure if they were frozen
or not he's right
voila pasta is fresh frozen that's the
most mind-boggling thing in this place
we make everything and then freeze it
chef the Twitter leaves are frozen are
they all Frozen they are so you
advertise you're making it daily but you
freeze it daily something's wrong big
time thank you
wow it's a totally news person
I can't I didn't even know this [__] me
either everything was like fresh it
makes no sense what to make it fresh and
then freeze it and then freeze it it
makes no sense
does anyone clean here
how often is this place cleaned I have
no idea you've got no idea when this
place was last cleaned they don't have a
cleaning crew all these
I'm not sure I'll have to ask John
what's that smell in here
[Music]
that's the smell oh my God what's in the
[__]
to have it was a little bit of a payback
because he just finished tearing me
apart I thought that was a little bit of
karma did I get you
from he overflooded it who watered the
plants this morning John they're full of
water somebody watered the plants
someone's doing a great job at watering
plants but not changing desserts
wow they'll pay for any dry cleaning
right okay
[Music]
forget it amigo
meatballs I enjoy but I know better
spaghetti meatballs spaghetti meatballs
um fresh meatballs are frozen frozen oh
come on
everything is Frozen
look at that now inside how rubber it
looks even before tasting it
how dry that is
dry disgusting frozen meatballs
meatballs are frozen rubbery and dry
she's right okay
every product you use in here is Frozen
when I first started here we cut up a
leg of veal and I'm still waiting to use
it
and here's your pizza
before Margarita Pizza is very greasy
yeah we've got oil sticks in here
doesn't like the pizza though it's too
greasy
it's full of grease Laurie the pizza's
grease is anything but what concerns
with John's behind the bar all this [__]
food's coming out and I want him to
taste what he's sending me because I'm a
little bit miffed to why I'm here
if no one's caring okay please sure well
you said the pizza is greasy and that
you should be tasting everything that
before it gets sent out to him
[__] have enough
oh boy
I know I don't know not enough
thank you
after being disappointed by Bland frozen
food and greasy pizza at Brooklyn's Mama
Maria's
Chef Ramsay heads to the kitchen looking
for an explanation I don't want to talk
to this guy when it comes in here
come on everybody outside uh introduce
me to who's who this is Joe Joe
this is Oscar how are you Hi how are you
come true hello how are you going to
meet you likewise good to see you too
um I don't know where to start I've just
had one of the most disgusting lunches
I've ever had
I stopped a dessert tray full of moldy
desserts and the tortellini grainy Bland
and the potato was just Dreadful the
meatballs Frozen dry solid yes they're
disgusting I don't need them but you
can't make meatballs every day
you get 20 pounds of chopped meat you
make the meatballs you freeze the rest
do you know how long it takes to make
five pounds of Meatballs 10 minutes what
we've done all our lifetime I haven't
just started this yesterday the
meatballs are always done if you get
away with it in 1967. it's 2012 John
does anyone have standards here we're
not in control of the menu whose menu is
this this is my menu I'm embarrassed to
do some of the things that we do here
are you kidding me we made pasta fresh
and we freeze it like are you crazy but
while you're doing it I don't have a
choice who's stopping you
the menu my menu
how do you listen to this man he's
spoken more since the last five minutes
than anybody has since I've been here do
you listen to your stuff they're not
paying my bills I'm the guy paying the
bills oh cause you make the pizza and so
they can't have a voice you should be
nowhere near this business
I don't agree with you I think we should
close the doors I don't think this man
actually gives a [__] I didn't call you
because I want to put the kids if I need
you to tell me to put the key to the
door I would have done that without you
coming in it worked before why can't it
work now but you're running on Nostalgia
it Stood Still and yet outside these
four walls the whole neighborhood has
overtaken you you're in love with the
Memories John
I don't know what to say
thank you for your honesty
I need a shower I [__] stink of plant
juice
I'm not going to close the doors but
just because he said he said so I don't
agree with him
[Music]
game on all right within a short time of
his arrival Chef Ramsay has discovered
that the staff may actually know more
than the owner what are we supposed to
do
we didn't [__] make these recipes and
now he's eager to see how the team
functions in a dinner service
oh my God
hello how are we doing welcome tomorrow
second course Papa Del tomato sauce
our boxes pizza boxes Grande before
rapido what's going on down here hello
business running as normal John yes this
is yes if I wasn't here you'd be doing
exactly the same exactly the same no
difference
[Music]
thank you
give me that Portobello clam I need that
first so that's what John would normally
do just all night on the pizzas out
there yeah I mean it doesn't come in
here he just stays out there all night
he's afraid I think he's afraid of the
kitchen he's afraid he owns the place I
know
it's crazy what is insane
is John seems content to pound away at
the pizza oven Margarita sauce Margarita
the kitchen led by Joe is pushing out
food at a steady Pace pick it up
here is your pasta if that doesn't mean
the fast arriving food
is pleasing the customers how's
everything
um the shells are like frozen it looks
like it's freezer burns all I got was
bro it's Rosemary all I taste is
Rosemary
I'm a vegetarian who's inside of this
song
Joe two seconds there's a bow and
arigatini this is vegetarian and the
tomato sauce they put pork bones in it
what the [__] she's vegetarian that's
how we do it every day
John is responsible for the methods that
we use to produce the food give me John
urgently who says if you don't like it
leave John this this is urgent now a
lady had just found a pork bone in the
registry we use to give the sauce but we
always always added sausage so you're
serving ball bones in the sauce for
vegetarian
that's how we prepare food for the last
40 years and I don't see it being a
problem a pork sauce to a [__]
vegetarian it's the way we've always
done our business you can't serve a
vegetarian a pork sauce
um what the [__] is going on here I know
what
that's [__] enough had enough I have
[__] enough
do you want me to order you a coffee
will that make it better
be okay because I can't hear you are you
waiting for the uh no
um my friend got sick is he vegetarian
no no what did he have it's a lobster
tail okay and the lobsters that tasted
um you're funny and next thing I knew is
sad
the general being sick of the bathroom
yeah he had Lobster at the mushrooms and
then you like a medical assistance would
you like for me to call 911 lobster tail
please I need one lobster tails it's
tough right I eat you guys thrown up
he's in the bathroom and he's sick
please show me exactly what you serve
that customer yeah please thank you
[__] hell
you all right okay no
yeah your Bluffs is ready
jump come here
seriously fishy I can smell the ammonia
yeah you smell that and that's what that
man's just eating
that's pneumonia that's what releases
when the body starts decompose has been
pulled apart and then decomposed that's
what makes it bad so just clarify
something for me we could possibly kill
them kill someone
and whilst we're discussing this and
there's a man vomiting in the toilet now
I can't believe this is happening right
now feels like [__] to know that you got
somebody sick and it's the first time
you've got your head out the dough but
it's John's responsibility no matter
what because John buys all the product
that we use yeah please
should we call an ambulance
hi this is Sal's Pizzeria I need an
ambulance the customer's not feeling
well
my worst fear is for anybody to get sick
in my restaurant where's a shot of
something I need a shot I need a shot of
something I got a guy vomiting give me
something give me a
quicker somebody came to your house and
you cooked them with dinner
how would you feel he started puking all
over the place
a guy had some Lobster and he has a
reaction to it the gentleman's sitting
down oh my God I think we just saw an
ambulance come out yes oh my God
needs to kill the cameras kill the
cameras
it's dinner service at Mama Maria's you
all right okay no one of the diners is
feeling ill after eating a questionable
Lobster
seriously fishing and that's what that
man's just eating and the paramedics
have just arrived on the scene a guy had
some Lobster and he has a reaction to it
the gentleman's sitting down it's
terrible if anybody to get sick on
anything that you serve you you I want
to stop everything just close the
[__] place down now okay so
whatever's been sir
I do not want to serve anything else
just stop everybody stop okay nothing
else leaves this kitchen unless it's
going in a garbage bag okay so when I
shut it down they'll just kick it with
apologize no check deeply sorry and we
have an issue that we have to deal with
my apologies
we need to close go to the tables tell
everybody they need to go no checks just
go okay awesome oh sorry but we're gonna
close the restaurant down soon
anything else it's embarrassing to have
paramedics walk into your restaurant and
to have to shut down your restaurant
because of that
should we take his contact information
or any kind of information like that
John can I have a word outside
[Music]
John tonight was beyond a disaster I
never expected this
never my wildest dreams Soul humiliation
but it's not just bad food John it's bad
practices that means you're so detached
from your business you don't look like
an owner you don't sound like an owner
you're like a member of Staff back there
you you're right but why
I don't know why I don't know why I just
because I think I've been beat up too
much
there's got to be some fight inside
there's got to be something I am a
fighter I've been a fighter my entire
life I was thrown into this place
because they needed to they needed a
horse a donkey to run the place because
they couldn't afford to hire people they
sacrificed my education and throw me in
here but you've given up
come on
you're destroying yourself
listen
I'll be changed
I will help you but you have to
understand you cannot be a member of
Staff pounding dough that's not right
you shouldn't be doing that
I do it because I love my family
I want to provide for that
that's why I know how
you think they get enjoyment watching
you kill yourself in there
John come on
you have to take a big long step back
and stop running this place from a
[__] pizza oven
I I can't I mean emotionally I can't why
I need to take a break
[Music]
oh yeah I want you to get some rest
no no no listen
you're an owner
hey I can see the pain I feel it let me
tell you I've got Fork is my own and I
know how hard it is but I'm here for you
and I want you to win understand that
man to man I'm telling you I want you to
win you've got to listen okay
we can do this right you don't want to
do it good
for my kids
okay
see you in the morning
Chef Ramsay may have pledged his help to
John but he needs to get a handle on
everything before he can Implement
changes so early this morning he does a
little research
[Music]
seeing how much frozen food there really
is
yes
they said they had frozen food but
look at the colors it's Frozen badly no
date no name look at it
oh kidding me
what is that
I mean honestly look at this [__]
yourself though what's that
that's just out of two freezers
and look there's more freezers down
there oh my God you are kidding me
chicken freezer burns oh man
this was five years old I was ruined you
can't cut that oh my God
oh Jesus this is a joke look at that oh
come on meatballs this is ridiculous
they're frozen molded what's that oh God
who takes the labels another freezer
frozen vegetables frozen pasta my God I
don't know what it is an ice cream
container some are filled with pasta
shells
oh my God
foreign
by the amount of frozen food wow Chef
Ramsay is determined to give John and
his staff unbelievable a much needed
wake-up call
[Music]
how easy I've got [__] day yesterday
yeah I've just spoken to Charles for
diner from last night he got checked out
this morning at the hospital totally
fine okay big breath of fresh air there
let me tell you I was really nervous
today we start fresh fortunately we are
still a little Frozen in the past
come with me oh boy let's go let me show
you something
come in WoW what the [__] is this that's
on menu what do you think it is
John
I've never ever encountered anything
like this in my entire cooking career
ever
that we had to not touch anything else
in this kitchen and cook what we've got
you'll be open for the next 12 months
and still not run out wow
[Music]
come on we have 40 Stacks that's like
400 pounds of chicken Kentucky Fried
Chicken probably doesn't have that much
chicken on hand
do you have any idea that this is going
on yes
it is it's it's amazing when you look at
it but I knew it was going on
meatballs
color hey don't throw it at me come on
guys there's more jokes I know there's
more downstairs there's more it pains me
you're right there's no there's no way
around it this is my this is my fault
it's a sad truth it is it lies with me
this is my fault
I let this get out of out of my grasp
the basketball we used to do 10 cases of
chicken in two weeks
I'm still buying like we were busy at
that at that level and why not the
restaurant is struggling as it is but
you're losing money twice as fast try to
change something that's no is that true
he's trying to change or say no yes
this resistance to change yes so that's
another my big problem like I told you
look at this how long do you think those
have been special
where's this from I I
how long has that been here
since my parents died
I don't want to take it down I don't
post the specials it's just something a
memory but that's the really important
issue and you must have take this
personally
you're still treating this business as
if Mum and Dad are here
[Music]
we have to let go
throw it out it's holding me onto the
pants throw it out no
okay yep
guys get the [__] out of here John let's
go
I am here to help you but I can just see
the pressure I can feel the frustration
I don't want to be here anymore
not that I don't want to be here I don't
want to be in this position no more
It's just sad just be in the air every
day working seven days a week I don't
know if I told you I wasn't educated my
mom and dad threw me in here I would
come home from school not to eat lunch
to serve lunch come on it's a kid eight
ten and this has been my life ever since
It's just sad to sit here every day
knowing what we used to do and not be
able to do what I used to do anymore
it's just holding on to the wrong things
and I think deep down
deep down he's Running Scared
I don't want to be scared
I want to fight my wife
I said my kids to camp
that was so happy that you were coming
my third child said to me
daddy where everything's gonna fix
everything that we get to bed one time
together
hey you will but you have got to let go
of the past
it's your turn now I am here to help to
help to understand but it's in one
condition you step away from that pizza
day
I want a commitment that you are not
gonna jump behind there on the safety
level it's going to be hard I just want
to commitment from you that you're going
to get your head out the door yeah so
yes I'm gonna start making it not
pounding it all right yeah
can you hear what's going on there here
that's for a reason
I hope they're listening
it's going to be extremely hard not to
fall back into your old habits but I'm
ready to from today on
change my ways and move forward and not
let that ever happen again
[Music]
Chef Ramsay clearly feels for this owner
and is now ready to reveal the first
important change
first of all good morning good morning
where are you but I don't see you don't
worry about that we are relaunching Mama
Maria's excited hey good remove your
blindfolds
oh my god wow
oh that awning's gone that's right the
awning has gone let me welcome you to
the new sign Mama Maria's when I first
arrived here I saw a disgusting awning
let us cut out just hideous this now is
your first statement it says a lot first
impressions let me tell you oh yeah I
like it it looks modern I've made some
minor changes inside minor trust them
when you walk through those doors I
think you're going to cramp yourself
let's go in come in
[Laughter]
first of all welcome to the new bright
vibrant Mama Maria's and my goodness
does it scream Brooklyn oh wow totally
different when I first came in here it
was resembling a restaurant that hadn't
been touched in years it was dark it was
grimy and it had no life we got stunning
turquoise walks that gives that nice
vibrant hop the custom artwork done by a
very talented artist painting the
beautiful historic Brooklyn Bridge above
your fireplace I like that I think this
is what Brooklyn wants and needs we got
rid of all the Clutter that John just is
holding on to we have
on the wall your parents in full-blown
stunning photographs which is an amazing
memory to hold on to oh have a look at
the paper
you didn't see that no that's me serving
the door I didn't notice the pictures
never forget this day moving forward a
new beginning in the history of the
stunning family run Mama Maria's let me
tell you this is my family this is me it
was here from my hands I didn't see it
it's amazing it's changing from old to
new what I letting go of the past the
past is still here with us and I got a
new lease online
Chef Ramsay's remodel of the restaurant
is only part of his master plan come
through please the overhaul of the menu
is the real key to turning this Brooklyn
Eatery around first of all just take a
look at the vibrancy looks great fresh
yeah that's what I want to that's what I
need right menu starting off with a
delicious bruschetta it's done with a
really nice chopped up mozzarella
instead of marinated tomatoes earthy
rustic and Charming brilliant and fresh
the mussels are just incredible a great
little appetizer to get the palette the
juice is Flowing the Specialties of the
house the pizzas Margarita stunning
simple delicious you hit it on ahead
next to that you've got the ozobuko
served and it's cooking juices over
mashed potato gremolata and a really
nice rich Demi glass I'm hungry you're
hungry that's a great sign boss
John what do you think I'm excited are
you excited yeah here's the scenario we
have some very very influential
journalists and bloggers coming in
everybody on their game yes yes one more
thing these little sprucing up
got this for you especially nice
beautiful shirt after 40 years I'm going
to take my colors off that's right
because you're no longer a pizza boy you
are the owner if I catch your head
inside that pizza oven I'll put it in
permanently
and as I look at you
look at you that's right and you are
gonna run this business just like they
did when they brought you into this
world you'll got it
it's relaunch night we've got some big
hitters in tonight yeah and Chef Ramsay
is determined to let everyone know that
Mama Maria's is the new cool place to
dine in Brooklyn
first off eating Brooklyn blogging
website Dynamic Blackboard eats blog
great we're gonna impress them eat to
blog are also joining us followed by the
New York Observer big one absolutely big
one getting nervous you have got a
Powerhouse full of critics look how
smart you are wow turn around give us a
spin
amazing amazing amazing let's go
welcome to Mama Maria's this is our
brand new manual welcome to Mama Maria's
relaunch and I'm very proud of what
we're doing now
[Music]
about two tops to come here just
recognize them a New York Observer the
guy with an iPad oh he's the man 2.4
million readers don't tell me who they
are because I've got nervous no I just
told you you need to know who they are
let's go you can do it it's tough taking
on this whole role you know it's not my
makeup I'll grab them okay two yeah I
need to step away from that pizza
counter and be more Hands-On to make
sure everybody's doing their job and
doing it correctly table four New York
Observer yes okay okay listen up first
course minestrone in a Caesar you got it
I need this risotto Cavatelli please 30
seconds in the window good while John
may be in the unfamiliar role of leading
his staff how are we going over here is
the pizza's all done there's another one
coming Mama Maria is off to a good start
pick up lasagna gnocchi spaghetti
meatballs and customers are thoroughly
enjoying the food is delicious I think
the sauce is spot on delicious but while
Chef Joe continues to push dishes out in
a timely manner muscles in the window
bruschetta in the window let's go was it
typical Southern Italian red sauce joint
yeah John seems to have forgotten that
he is still needed in his new role as
leader I'm so hungry
table four in the window let's go it's a
vloggers table guys let's go Rapido it's
very frustrating when I see dishes not
leaving the window there's no time for
mistakes I got time for this where is
John
let's go get me John let me go are you
serious right now son of a [__] there's
a guy walking around here with a white
jacket blonde hair oh [__] sake John
yes sir so you can't just favor two guys
at the bar you've got to be everywhere
right right and now we're in the middle
of service I'm not letting you think
that I'm angry no this place is
influential bloggers step up
we have to encourage don't stop you
cannot stop
we're going to communicate with our team
still got VIP tables out there okay this
stuff I'll take it out okay beautiful
let's not drop our heads let's bounce
back okay here you go guys
so happy sorry about this service we're
trying our best we're trying to keep up
and we're trying to do whatever we can
this is the first time John was acting
like the owner he is tonight doing great
you're doing great all right keep it up
and that's exactly what Mama Maria needs
that's what's awesome
let me know when that Margarita is ready
please I need that Margarita so guys how
did everything go the spaghetti
meatballs
great job well done here have a good
night thank you thank you bye thank you
John listen you are one hard-working
honest guy thank you I feel I was living
in a shell I'm coming out of that shop
okay shell is broken because and I'm
gonna be honest with you you hit it man
you hit it right on the head here's my
memories Mum and Dad are here yeah there
yeah and so they are looking down
and they right now I'm proud you have
got the door open and grab it just go
forward don't go away no no I'm not
going backwards I refuse to go backwards
because one thing I remember my father
was his leadership and that's what I'm
going to continue doing thank you so
much take care of yourself I know what I
need to do and there's more to come of
Mama Maria's in the future
for the last 55 years this restaurant
has belonged to John's parents and even
after they sadly passed away he remained
a pizza maker but tonight he was an
owner this restaurant now belongs to
John and John only and I'm truly and I
mean truly rooting for this Brooklyn
underdog
how much water can be put in one plant
pot
[Music]
God bless pizzas
after Chef Ramsay left welcome to Mama
Maria John has kept his promise of
running his business away from the pizza
counter I need a bowl of grated cheese
please a bowl of grated cheese Mama
Maria's has already generated a ton of
positive buzz from bloggers and websites
that's really good thank you I'll help
him Chef Ramsay we've come a long way
and this 55 year old restaurant is on
its way back to being a fixture in
Brooklyn once again